bonjour
vous savez c'est agréable de se donner
un peu de fraîcheur par cette chaleur
mobo casimir j'ai une chose très
ennuyeuse à te demander allons bon
venant de vous je m'attends à tout ah
bon voila tu sais que chacun à notre
tour nous devons balayer le jardin oui
hé hé hé hé aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est à mon tour
un très bien soyez tranquille vous
pouvez avoir confiance et comme si
c'était fait abu casimir je suis étonné
mais je suis rassuré qu'ils le prennent
de si bon coeur bon très bien alors je
pars tranquille
auquel barbe alors genre de balayer mois
et inde casimir quoi qu'ils auront
encore vous mais justement j'étais en
train de m'activer a balayé oui et avec
quoi casimir pas avec le ballet parce
que j'avais oublié de te laisser jeu
venu te le donne et va justement j'étais
en train de me poser la question je me
disais un casimir il te manque quelque
chose mais quoi et hop voilà on m'a
apporté la réponse le bal un bon jeu
repart mais moins tranquille que la
première fois à
tien casimir et je téléphonerai pour
savoir où tu en es dans ton balayage
bombe mais qu'est ce que c'est que ces
manière dont je me surveiller comme ça
j'ai horreur de ça bon puisque c'est ça
je vais regarder voler les mouches à
eau non non non mais vraiment casimir
exagère mais pile quelques temps il est
de plus en plus paresseux c'est
évidemment s'il était parfait ça
certainement beaucoup moins amusé tient
à raison mais ne bougent pas françois je
vais lui parler moi
casimir tu sais je n'ai pas de conseil à
donner les tu ferais mieux de travailler
avant de s'amuser mais pourtant c'est ce
que tu fais toujours toi
toujours rose tout
enfin c'est vrai que je le fais souvent
oh tu vois écoute julie g j'ai une idée
j'aimerais que tu m' apprennent à danser
le tango argentin oui d'accord d'accord
attention hein tu me manques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allo
oui
vous voulez parler à casimir oui ne
quittez pas ne quittez pas je l'appelle
mais voilà qui dansent le tango avec
julie au lieu de balles il jardin
casimir mon vieux hop on te demande au
téléphone en question je ne connais pas
qui en est même je ne sais pas mais je
n'ai pas l'habitude de répondre à
n'importe qui vont déjà devoir à nous
casimir voudrais savoir qui vous êtes
c'est vous monsieur décide à new york
chez j'avais pas reconnu votre voix ne
quittez pas casimir casino mon vieux
c'est monsieur des snowboards je m'en
doutais il veut sa défaite 3d des
nouvelles du balisage 10 nuits quand je
ne suis pas là c'est pas possible que
seigneur je viens de lui dire le
contraire hommes et tu aurais dû lui
dire attendez un instant je vais voir si
lille a éconduit quand jean téléphone
sur une honte en ligne art comme tu veux
doit alors messieurs les snobs oui je
suis désolé mais il est impossible à
casimir de vous répondre pour l'instant
veuillez rappeler plus tard je vous
remercie
casimir s'est arrangé pour cette fois
mais ne compte plus sur moi dorénavant
d'ailleurs il faut que j'aille jusqu'au
port au bâton sans toi je te suis parce
que raconter des histoires à monsieur du
sne apprentis téléphone bon je vous en
prie emmené vie hein tu es triste sommes
pas là mais tu sais kazemi a aussi son
toit nous ennuyons beaucoup oui mais il
y a également que lorsque vous n'êtes
pas là je dois regarder le kiosque et
servir les clients c'est très fatigant
qu'elle lui un bien puisque c'est comme
ça casimir nous te laisse aux seuls sans
aucun remord vient julien haut ce qu'ils
sont susceptibles alors bon on était
déjà à huy là bas les ja dans le
hall e joli papillon et aux papillons
papillon vient là mais non je ne veux
pas capturé je veux seulement te serrer
la main bien papillon
ça y est monsieur du sna brawn et sa
décrocherait genou ne décrocherait spa
voilà toute la question
l'idée alors qu'aucune il n'y a pas
d'abonnés au numéro que vous avez
demandé il n'y a pas de
tulle a raccroché ça a marché
pour le bel oiseau un petit oiseau vient
revient là oiseaux bien nous allons
chanter au sens où la petite oiseaux
au se casse pieds de monsieur du sma à
bon port
alors ici c'est léonard oh non non non
casimir les plans non il reviendra plus
tard quoi abo olalala
il dit la rive dans dix minutes cette
fois il faudrait que je me dépêche
allons-y
[Musique]
enfin il était temps je vois monsieur du
snop qui arrive à casimir j'ai cherché
en vain d'avoir au téléphone ah bon ce
n'est pas possible je suis pas au
courant j'avais quelque chose
d'important à te dire arriver arriva
dites le moi des fois non non non c'est
trop tard casimir mais enfin pourquoi et
bien en consultant la liste chez moi
j'ai constaté que je ne t'ai pas ton
tour mais le mien oh non je vais aller
jeter son corps à la mer à milan en
poupe à casimir pourquoi ce qu'en
regardant la liste j'ai constaté aussi
que demain c'est ton tour de la ligue et
on se téléphone
[Musique]